qu'ils s'appellent et sécurité
informatique problème et résolution nous
sommes prêts et nous sommes heureux de
vous accueillir je veux répéter encore
une fois passé que c'est sincère nous
sommes ravis de vous accueillir
pendant ce temps et qui est vraiment
compliquée à cause des obstacles liés
avec la cobi 19 mai quand même nous
sommes à tout ce dont nous sommes réunis
pour discuter et trouver des solutions
communes
et avant de commencer le travail
j'aimerais vous dire quelques mots à
propos du règlement parce que le sujet
suscitait un grand intérêt il y avait
beaucoup d'intervenants et surtout ceux
qui ont voulu faire des allocutions et
qu'ils sont inscrits et d'avancer c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais demander à vous
tous séduits suivre strictement les
règlements sauf les premiers pas ce que
c'est que vont lancer la discussion
on va faire une petite exception le
temps de l'intervention va varier entre
5 7 minutes avec la démonstration des
diapos et j'espère votant pour une
discussion
et pour passer questions réponses est
s'il par contre j'ai pas présenté tous
les experts qui sont devant vous et ceux
qui ont préparé alors une question d'
avance je vais passer la part
directement parce que le sujet de la
sécurité informatique et de pollution
informatique est déjà dans l'oeuf aucune
autre conférence pendant la sixième
année et même ici en 2015
c'était sortes de sujets
innovateur de complément mais comme je
vous avez pu en temps pendant les
allocutions de ministre de la défense
monsieur sergueï choïgou et le directeur
du service fédéral de sécurité ça
devenir le mail stream
parce que tout le monde est pratiquement
tellement me même adversaire il accepte
le fait que l'opposition directe ou
indirecte mais les terres tout de métaux
ce qui concerne la position dans
l'espace informatique et cyber
malheureusement sert de l'environnement
opérationnel qui est inscrite et où des
critères comme la zone grise des actions
opérationnelles dans les doctrines
américaine où il n'y a aucune règle
limitation en vigueur et les questions
de paix et de guerre sont résolus parce
que l'éventail de ménage et la notion de
la guerre change aussi est la ligne
rouge de cette opposition dont on parle
beaucoup sur à définir au futur pour
assurer la stabilité stratégique dont
nous parlons tous ensemble pendant
toutes les sessions plénières mais
aujourd'hui il est évident que l'une des
lignes rouges et de cette opposition se
trouva dans la ville de à new york à
manhattan dans le bâtiment de l'onu
et j'espère que tout se passe bien avec
la communication parce qu'aujourd'hui
heureusement voilà c'est le cas
aujourd'hui nous avons la participation
à la plate forme de dialogue
le plus important est moi je le meur de
passer la parole au représentant
permanent de russie à l'onu
le baladeur pénitentiaire les plus parmi
les plus connus dans le monde entier
vassili ni benzia bonjour chers facile
et ce constat et bonjour je vous entends
très bien je sais passe plus je dois
vous répondre je suis ravi de vous
entendre de vous écouter
maintenant pour ne pas perdre le temps
je passe la parole pour qu'il puisse y
est ouvrir et entamer notre discussion
pendant les premières dix minutes
merci cher andré chers collègues
j'aimerais commencer par féliciter le
ministère de la défense russe et les
sommes mises acteurs de la 9e conférence
de moscou sur la sécurité internationale
parce que cet événement a une réputation
du fonds parmi les plus importants
consacrés à la sécurité et d'une année à
l'autre les réunit les représentants il
des militaires des diplomates et des
sociétés communauté civile et moi
personnellement j'avais participé à
l'époque où je travaillais à moscou et
aujourd'hui j'ai l'honneur de
d'intervenir à partir de new york
évidemment ce dialogue et multi format
est extrêmement important parce que nous
permet d'y étudier les sujets cela sous
différents angles pour rechercher un
nouveau prisme politique évidemment ça
tout s'est fait favorise la recherche de
nouvelles solutions politiques
et comme j'ai déjà dit j'ai l'honneur de
d'ouvrir ses survenir consacrée à la
sécurité informatique international et
parcourir mais moi je vais faire part de
leurs pulsions universelle je pense que
ce sujet à partir d'un sujet et 3 c'est
devenu l'un des axes les plus importants
de la diplomatie internationale
ce que nous ressentons ici directement
sur la plateforme à new york
il ya donc deux raisons ce dont le
progrès technologique est extrait mec
qui a résulté en fait où nous sommes
tous devenus dépendants de technologie
zink artificielle des réseaux de
télécommunications des prestations et
asik décrypte devise de l'intelligence
artificielle et c'est alice enrichit
pratiquement tous les jours et le monde
est devenu du poisson incontournable
numérique et je peux vous dire que le
sujet de la numérisation
c'est un des sujets parmi les plus
populaires au sein de l'onu surtout au
sein de l'assemblée générale la passe
qui suscite un intérêt gigantesque qui
est chaque année nos fictions de plus
dans plus d'initiatives consacré à ce
sujet c'est évidemment tous les états
surtout les états en développement ont
l'intérêt avoir l'accès le plus large
possible aux acquis du numérique qui
donne de nouvelles opportunités pour le
développement de l'économie et la
prospérité et le développement de la
prospérité de leur population
camélée programme un autre côté de l'âme
de la monnaie parce que on est obligé de
faire face aux menaces de cyber espace
parce qu'il devions l'arène pour
l'opposition et différentes
manipulations et compétition maloney et
certains pays en essayant d'utiliser à
la pollution de force de la pause et
leurs règles du jeu malheureusement les
accusations de cyberattaques malfondet
devienne un très bon prétexte d'une
pression politique qui sur les
assurances pour intensifier les
pressions en même temps le domaine
numérique est envahie par les criminels
du point de vue de la géopolitique le
progrès dans le domaine des technologies
d'informatique créer un nouvel équilibre
de forces sur l'arène mondiale
évidemment la compétition politique n'a
pas disparu et nous voyons l'envi de
pays d'enrichir de développer leurs
armes d'attac mais quand même par
rapport aux cibles potentielles nous
voyons le nouveau l'équilibré
il s'agit de nouveaux risques d'un
paradoxe qui n'existait pas avant dans
le cas du paradigme nationale plus le
niveau d'incertitude de développement
est élevé plus vulnérables devient son
processeur est tous les joueurs sont
obligés de prendre en considération ce
facteur est de petite et de grande
taille
peu importe et les défis dans le
cyberespace qui sait quoi en
géométriques et ce temps des problèmes
clés sur l'agenda international qui
suscite cette grande attention et nous
en tant que diplomate que nous y voyons
tout d'abord une très bonne possibilité
unique source améliorer les relations
entre les états où tout le monde est
venu à bhl est interdépendant et malgré
les oppositions des parties parfois très
sérieuse quand même c'est ce que nous
voyons à partir de new york il ya assez
de choses positives déjà l'atmosphère de
discussion sur la plateforme de l'onu
diffère par rapport à d'autres
plateformes parce qu'ils pensent dans
les dernières négociations les positions
ainsi que sur d'autres axes nous avons
nous voyons plus sûr pour d'autres
sujets
les positions d'été
et pendant plusieurs décennies mais est
ce qui concerne la sécurité informatique
les parties essaient de participer avec
intérêt à ces discussions pour trouver
les points de convergence et en plus on
essaie de rajouter une interaction
bilatérale dans différents pays pour ce
sujet c'est un très bon exemple afin de
réduire la méfiance est réciproque
par rapport à la diplomatie de megaton
qui utilisait parfois par nos
partenaires
la russie fait non seulement
contribution à ce processus mais fait
une grande contribution constructive pas
ce qu'ils sont devenus
l'auteur en 1998 déjà et je suis fier de
vous annoncer que depuis plus de 20 ans
nous gardons ici est le drapeau russe
surtout les sommets stratégie parce que
depuis 1998 l'assemblée générale de
l'onu adopté
d'après notre initiative les acquis et
les avancées dans le contexte de la
sécurité internationales dans le domaine
de technologies informatiques et 7 jours
sur la jante adier comité de l'onu
et c'est grâce à la russie pendant et 15
ans au sein de la new nous avons
organisé des groupes de travail
d'experts sur la sécurité informatique
on titille gibier en détail ce sujet en
d'après notre initiative et avec le
soutien de nos partenaires nous avons
lancé le premier ouvert à tous les états
membres mécanismes de négociation et
consultations sur la sécurité
informatique ce qui est devenu un jalon
très important parce que pour la
première fois l'accès à la discussion de
ces problèmes a été donné à la majorité
de l'onu
notre logique là dessus être
simple parce que nous visons pour un
dialogue ouvert et sincère
si tout le monde est pareil à face aux
menaces informatiques
tout le monde ça veut dire toute la
panne pouvoir participer à cette
discussion on devrait éviter aucune
imposition de la part de ceux qui se
considèrent en tant que les plus
avancées et je veux confirmer que le
premier groupe de ses compositions a
fini ce travail par adopter rapport de
consensus ce qui représente un résultat
de compromis où tous les 193 pays du
monde sont capables de se mettre
d'accord sur la sécurité nationale
concernant les mesures à entreprendre à
l'horizon de deux ans parce que même il
ya cinq ans on nous a dit que c'est pas
possible du tout à cause de la
différence d'opinion mais quand même le
fait le témoigne l'année dernière nous
avons franchi une autre étape importante
parce que le format s'est établi au sein
de la nuit des princes est il de russie
on établit un groupe de travail qui
fonctionnera pendant cinq ans à venir
qui va discuter des problèmes dans le
domaine informatique surtout les droits
de comportements responsables des états
dans le monde ont la première fois la
charte de ces règles a été formulée en
2018 où la majorité des états membres de
l'onu
quand je vais à 10 a adopté les
résolutions de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu qui avait été proposé par la
russie en ce qui concerne le sujet de
l'opposition les résistances à la
cybercriminalité
la russie joue un rôle initiateur parce
que nous agissons pour l'adoption d'une
nouvelle convention internationale pour
prévenir l'utilisation des technologies
informatiques accenture aux fins
criminelles et tu dois prendre en
considération l les intérêts de tous les
pays basée sur la non ingérence dans
leurs affaires internes en 2019 la
russie avance initiative de créer un
comité spécialisé sous l'égide de l'onu
pour préparer le projet de cette
convention
là dessus nous avons aussi un progrès et
en mai dernier avec le soutien
responsables des états membres de l'onu
nous avons adopté une autre résolution
visant et plus rendant possible de
lancer cette discussion pour finaliser
ce document vers de mes 23 et comment le
président russe vladimir poutine a dit
au cours de la réunion du conseil de
sécurité de la fédération de russie le
23 mai 2010 à 20h l'approché concernant
à la garantie de la sécurité
internationales elle reste intacte et
nous pensons nécessaire de conclure les
accords lé traité visant à assurer le
partenariat mutuellement avantageux et
au cours de ce chemin vers cet objectif
il faut créer des règles de comportement
des états membres dans l'espace
informatique pour éviter des actions d'
inacceptable et pour les rendre karaté
juridique obligatoire pour qu'ils soient
respectives de façon sévère et absolue
par tous les états membres
en conclusion j'aimerais soulever un
comtois qui chilienne bonne volonté
politique on peut il faut se mettre
d'accord sur la sécurité informatique ça
pourrait répondre aux intérêts de tous
les états membres et pour nous ça
commence par le travail et les exemples
de nos partenaires occidentaux surtout
le dernier sommet russo américain a
démontré et qu'il faut reprendre le
dialogue sur la sécurité informatique en
temps il a réussi
et les états unis je pense que c'est un
peu trop tôt de faire des prévisions
mais quand même ça pourrait assurer une
pension complémentaire pour lancer ces
discussions au sein de l'union nous
sommes toujours prêts à se mettre
d'accord pour mettre en place un bon
dialogue et diplomatiques et dans ce
contexte nos portes sont ouvertes pour
nos partenaires à l'orient et l'occident
et je remercie tous pour la possibilité
d'ouvrir île de nauru reste cette
session parce que malheureusement je
dois je fais pas assisté au cours de
toute la session mais j'aimerais vous
remercier encore une fois tout chaud que
je remercie je demande de laisser
l'image vous avez parlé de cette
nouvelle équation des risques et des
menaces actuelles
croyez moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous il s'agit de la technologie d
assurer la gestion mondiale à travers la
terreur la peur est ce que la russie
fait surtout sur la plateforme de l'onu
grâce à vous et je vous en remercie
encore une fois il s'agit de crier au
monde qui gît sur la confiance et
j'espère que notre travail durant cette
conférence nous aidera à faire en bas ou
à quitter le monde est géré par la peur
et aboutir dans le monde a eu ni j-100
sur la confiance je vous remercie
restez d'alexis chaque collègue comme
notre représentant permanent à l'onu
vient de dire le monde et dans
changements permanents
c'est tout à fait évident et une minute
russe de la défense a aussi parlé en
inaugurant notre conférence est
l'accent de
la politique internationale est de plus
en plus déplacée de l'atlantique et au
sud et sud-est c'est une tendance plutôt
global et de long terme
erreur dans la région du sud de sud-est
7 mac os région reste l'endroit de
confrontation des intérêts des plus
grandes puissances ce qui est rend les
évitant le coc vivre un état entre la
guerre et la paix nous avons invité de
participer un autre discussion le
premier vice-ministre de la défense de
l'un des plus grands pays du monde
leurs deux plus grands pays musulmans la
république islamique du pakistan où
l'importance de leur nez dans le domaine
d'assurer la stabilité le positionnement
du pays à l'international
ce rôle n'est pas à sous-estimer c'est
avec grand plaisir que je passe la
parole à monsieur le premier vie c'est
comme vice ministre de la défense de la
république islamique du pakistan
général hussein
mon général vous pouvez profiter de la
tribune où intervenir d'autres fauteuils
quand vous le voulez
excellence les indians mesdames et
messiers c'est un grand plaisir de
participer à conférences internationales
de moscou sur la sécurité internationale
c'est en une plateforme importante pour
discuter des questions de la sécurité
globale je tiens aura commencé par
exprimer mes remerciements aux
organisateurs de la conférence
c'est un grand plaisir de parler avoue
sur la situation économique en asie du
sud
surtout dans le contexte de la lutte
contre le terrorisme la pandémie de
lakovic 19
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais
commencer par dresser notre vision de la
situation globale et stratégique et qui
nous démontrent des fortes modifications
liées au passage de monde unipolaire à
au monde multipolaire le développement
du centre de gravité économique y est
déjà évident dans la manipulation de
l'information à l'échelle globale dans
l'espace et cybernétique la lutte contre
le protectionnisme est allé
recrudescence des forces occultes droite
dans la folie dans la politique du monde
entier le système équilibre global et
répond aux intérêts des paquets ce temps
notre pays participe de façon actif
entre invalidante elle un nouveau
consensus dans le domaine de contrôle
des armements bas la non prolifération
le désarmement pakistan est persuadé qu
le régime global des normes
prolifération ne doit pas porter des
traits de destiny descrimination pour
devenir garant du monde de la stabilité
internationale il doit reconnaître le
droit égal à tous les états à respect de
leur sécurité
c'est pourquoi pakistan aspire à
promouvoir en ordre mondial juste basée
sur des règles et des valeurs notre
situation régionale est caractérisée par
la rivalité des grandes puissances près
des portes de l'asie du sud
le la présence accrue des troupes à des
forces armées la création des
différentes alliances de toutes sortes à
la l'octroi allende le statut de
prestataire m pure de sécurité à la
sortie des troupes américains de
l'aghanistan et cessé de tomber la
diplomatie
de la diplomatie coercitive basé au
resto par la disponibilité des
ressources d'eau tout ça génère la
préoccupation à nous avons aussi ce
différend déjà me de cachemire qui sert
un obstacle à notre voie la voie de la
stabilité de la paix régionale
les menacent la stabilité stratégique en
asie du sud est renforcée par le
caractère nucléaire de l'océan indien
l'augmentation de la diversité de la
portée de la puissance des fleurs ce
qu'on vend des armes conventionnelles et
nucléaires
les
[Musique]
le déploiement des systèmes antimissiles
les essais d earn de grande et de grande
portée
nos comptes en ass cul les acteurs et
juno assument leurs responsabilités
analyse l' influence de leur stratégie
géopolitique sur le sort de la région de
la gym sud est de l'océan de randien
l'octroi du rôle d'adam fournisseurs pur
de sécurité à ces délits éléments à des
gouvernements inspirant être seul
peut-être ses pouvoirs c'est une notion
qui n'est pas compatible au droit de
tous les pays se verront à être sans
danger en sécurité mesdames et messieurs
la paix la stabilité en asie du sud est
ne sont pas imaginable sans la
résolution des différends persistant
sans la concertation des mesures
communes pour la le désarmement et la
dissuasion nucléaires et conventionnels
sans l'instauration de l' équilibre des
forces conventionnelles par le biais de
dialogues visant à renforcer la
confiance mutuelle
notre activité qui vise à créer la
stabilité à régional aspire à l'assuré à
travers la coopération mesdames et
messieurs mes temps je parlais de rôles
des deux ne fermait dans le
contre-terrorisme et à la prévention de
la commue 19 pakistan a connu un succès
inouï dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
et l'extrémisme
étant donné que les ressources ne sont
pas énormes
en commençant par les opérations shared
interest in i just had et maintenant
façade
nous avons payé de notre sang pour
chaque pas de progression
nous avons pays c'est route par de
multiples pertes
l'économie pakistanaise a perdu 130
milliards de dollars des etats-unis et
des pertes à 1 en direct au niveau de
500 bières omettant grâce à dieu nous
avons su restaurer activité normale des
régions mise en ruine auparavant nous
avons su intégrer ces régions dans la
totalité des filles les fermes et du
pakistan ensemble avec le gouvernement
et d'autres institutions sont en train
de réaliser de nouvelles réformes
le plan national d'action est en cours
d'être réalisé la position ferme de
notre nation à servir et protéger les
valeurs universelles et assurer la
victoire
décisif sur le terrorisme mesdames et
messiers mais tanger pas ce défi lancé
par la part des médias qu'avait 19 je
dois dire que le pas qui cela est un
exemple d'une riposte efficace à ce défi
le concept de blocage micro blocage vous
blocage intelligents nous a permis de
retenir la pandémie en poursuivant notre
activité économique apport pakistan on a
connu une hausse économique assez
considérable tandis qu'une nouveaux
agents ont été ont perdu beaucoup de
croissance économique nous avons créé un
centre de commandement et de contrôle
pour élaborer le
au programme national de la lutte contre
l accueil de ce centre a assuré la
coordination de service médical vient
les institutions de la santé publique et
les hôpitaux militaires
grâce à ces travaux pakistan et peut
servir de l'exemple de la lutte efficace
contre la pandémie
mesdames et messieurs les opérations
d'information et de sensibilisation sont
à la base de notre succès comme pour le
thé contre le terrorisme ou prévenir
lakovic 19 nos institutions nationales
et un au führer mais on d'assurer le
soutien informationnel l'informatique de
nos activités en profitant des
technologies cybernétiques des réseaux
numériques et pour répondre à la coved
nous avons crié en centre national de
commandement de contrôle rampant à
cordes incore denis assurer la
coordination des activités de plusieurs
acteurs luttant contre la pandémie
conclure je tiens à dire que pakistan
soutient les initiatives globales visant
à assurer la stabilité et le
développement durable il est important
d'éviter toutes sortes de mesures qui
sont de nature à saper la stabilité
internationale la stabilité stratégique
par naji en asie du sud exige la
résolution des différents jeux
politiques et qui persiste et les fermes
et de pakistan en contribue toujours à
la cause d' assurer la sécurité contre
toute sorte de menace en terre nord
externe ce qui remettait dans la
participation de nos forces armées nomme
la lutte contre le terrorisme et à la
prévention de la ville 19 et pour
conclure
je fais dire que nous avons beaucoup
fait nous avons fait ce transfert de jeu
politique à l'économie nous aurons sur
nous focaliser à des composants plus
plus important de ce blog en créant de
nouvelles solutions en faisant appel à
tous nos ressources et nous le faisons
pour instaurer la paix pour protéger nos
frontières je le remercie de votre
attention
je le remercie en général alors chers
collègues
on continue notre discussion revient en
europe
et c'est avec grand plaisir que je passe
la parole
un représentant de l'un des pays les
plus puissants de l'europe
[Musique]
l'udr dans parti qui n'est pas au
pouvoir mais parmi les partis les plus
importants de l'allemagne l'alternative
pour l'allemagne les points clés qui
sont développés par le parti parce son
leader qui ne craint pas là qui est
devant nous c'est la démographie a les
problèmes de migration l'inefficacité du
régime des sanctions
les questions de ce vernis t de
l'allemagne y compris dans le domaine
informatique et parfois on a des
questions posées dans le en matière de
la politique écologique ce qui génère
une forte critique et à l'intérieur de
l'allemagne et en dehors du pays
mais les allemands sont de plus en plus
nombreux à voter pour ce parti
la participation ici maintenant avec
nous
lorsque nous venons de commémorer les 80
ans du début de la grande guerre
patriotique il eut la russie a perdu et
vend sept millions de ses compatriotes 8
millions c'était des pertes et
militaires est le reste les 19 c'était
des civils est le fait qu nos co doyon
maintenant le représentant de
l'allemagne
en politicien les durs du parti
important ça c'est de la confiance ça
c'est c'est vraiment important je vous
remercie pour votre participation et je
vous passe la parole
notre excellence monsieur le ministre de
l'enfance général colonel le féminicide
ni de ce qui le fait d'avoir cette
opportunité de vente et revenir
nettement durant cette conférence mais
très important c'est avec beaucoup
d'intérêt que j'ai écouté le discours de
monsieur poutine en 2003 en allemagne
lors de cet assaut du secours aux
poutine a présenté la politique de la
main tendue qui a auraient dû tracer
l'itinéraire de notre coopération
ultérieure
les gens en allemand on était vraiment
encourager nous avons connu de la
confrontation de la guerre
un peu de tout mais a créé en futur
comment en futur claira basée à la
confiance le respect mutuel c'était si
près 6 espérés
et malheureusement la russie l'allemagne
n'ont pas su le faire l'europe est
divisée maintenant de nombreux pays sont
divisés de l'antérieur les propagandes
les fausses informations techniques
c'est ça ce qui conditionne notre vie
après le conflit entre l'orient et
l'occident
les puissances extérieures influence les
discussions internes d'un pays et le
nord stream ii en feront très bon
exemple les pays
je menace des cinq sion la prise de
décision et a heurté contre des
argumentations idéologique ou morale qui
ne sont pas toujours valable bien qu'il
s'agisse de prendre des sujets en se
basant l'assouvir unités
allemande on trouve des manipulateurs
qui ne se font pas guidée par des
intérêts allemands ni pas d enterrer des
européens qui veulent avoir des
ressources énergétiques et à des prix
abordables
on nous sommes sous la pression et nous
devons agir contre nos entériné une
contre nos besoins et cheminots comme
suit nous voyons cet échange d opinion
qui est violée qui est manipulé des
formes et tout ce qui est utilisé par
nos partenaires pour défendre leurs
propres intérêts stratégiques
on exerce de l'affluence mentales
cognitives non seulement sur les
institutions il faut des fraudes
personnalité mais venus pour des suites
loyer ensemble nous témoignons à des
opérations psychologiques qu'on croit
être un outil légitime les antes a
démoralisé l'adversaire et à sa
population dans l'oeil dans le pendant
la guerre qui est appelé en russie non
comme la grande guerre patriotique là
les troupes allemandes ont commencé à
faire reprendre des tracts démoraliser
la population locale et les troupes
après la seconde guerre mondiale les
opérations psychologiques s'était déjà
les allemands qui ont carrément été
sensible ce qui a beaucoup influencé
notre identité nationale et notre
culture est la guerre froid qui a suivi
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale a
été caractérisée par la lutte acharnée
entre les idéologies majeurs dans le
monde les médias les établissements de
culture et d'enseignement ont porté leur
contribution à la lutte informatique des
deux parties adverses en précédant de
prouver leur supériorité morale
je veux citer un autre exemple s'il
s'agit de la guerre de l'irak et les
deux parties ont utilisé les
journalistes et les médias en tant qu
une partie active de leur stratégie
alors la partie ira keane a essayé de
démontrer les images est choquant des
pertes parmi les civils et les enfants a
incité une indignation de la part des de
la population occidentale de la société
a aussi dans ta les américains ont fait
autrement ils ont fait démontré les
reportages de la ligne de front a lésé
par le propre journalistes pour
présenter sédières commune en croisade
et saine et les offenses les preuves qui
ont été présentés pourraient justifier
l'intrusion
ensuite ont été reconnus nul mais la
chose était déjà fait
l'information est disponible pour tout
le monde alors les manipulations
informatiques et exercé une énorme
influence et ont toujours une importance
accrue
nous n'avons pas encore atteint le
sommet le top de nos capacités dans le
domaine informatique dit fixer les airs
mais de bottes
avons nous faire confronter à de
nouvelles menaces de nouveaux défis
aujourd'hui chacun peut trouver à
l'internet ce qu'il veut on trouve
toutes sortes de théories et des pignons
qui se sont répandues par tout le monde
les gens sont faciles à mettre manipuler
pour former leurs soi-disant propre
opinion en se basant à de fausses
actualité les conditions géopolitiques
sont aussi beaucoup changé
les auparavant on avait deux grandes
idéologies opposées dans le monde actuel
multipolaire on trouve en grand nombre
de pays avec leurs propres terres et
leurs propres voleurs qui sont en
concurrence permanente
nous témoignons des processus dynamique
est tout à fait nouveau la lutte de
nouvelles technologies et la lutte pour
la supériorité économique et politique
exerce son influence à tous les domaines
de la vie ce qui est venu à la relève
des processus d'auparavant le rôle de
l'espace et cybernétique issue voit être
renforcés par des menace est externe et
interne dans le domaine digital a entre
époque de digitalisation de nouvelles
technologies la déclaration de guerre
n'existe plus du tout façon formelle les
services secrets des ong et des médias
jours à ces jeux d ombres en profitant
de l'information et de désinformation
le partout il faut violé sept telle
confiance entre le citoyen et les
gouvernements ces mesures sont utilisés
comme une partie intégrante des
stratégies d'information
dans le futur nous devons vivre dans le
nouvelle réalité et comment faire face à
ces défis
c'est la question à laquelle nous devons
trouver quelle cité des réponses
ensemble comment pouvons-nous
neutraliser la propagation de foetus de
fausses informations
comment vont tomber pourra-t-on mettre
fin à cet afflux de notification
informatique à l'air en perdition qui
sont décrites et ne sont pas des
recettes uniques et pour apparaît cette
menace ça ne fait que générer de
nouveaux problèmes de nouveaux défis
aujourd'hui je vous parle non seulement
en ma fonction de co-président du parti
la qualif pour l'allemagne mais entendre
qu'une que la cure
le président d'une grande partie de
position allemande alors je peux
discuter à toutes sortes de questions
avec vos bien que la liberté
d'information est limitée par des
opposants politiques et mon parti
politique tient à promouvoir les valeurs
qui sont propres à notre pays pour
aspirer à la prospérité
y compris dans le domaine de la
politique extérieure mais enterré
coïncide avec les intérêts de
l'allemagne
nous sommes toujours favorables à mon
relation de l'allemagne avec la russie
et la chine et la chine mais ça
s'inscrit pas dans la ligne de la
politique extérieure actuelle de
l'allemagne
pour conclure je veux dire que nous
n'arriverons nulle malheureusement pas
participer avant toutes sortes de
conférences pareil parce que les médias
mise sous contrôle du régime à actuel ne
nous donne pas la parole à pour la lutte
et politique intérieure non nous voyons
les voleurs qui sont propres à notre
pays
il s'agit en fait le respect des valeurs
culturelles des valeurs sociales et de
la religion et de l'environnement la
connaissance et c'est la force et les
manipulations ont toujours eu leur place
dans les sociétés les esprits peuvent
hésiter et les gens qui ont peu
d'informations sont légèrement à
manipulable ces deux faits réels et nous
allons aboutir si nous allons travailler
ensemble et ne pas et non pas les uns
contre les autres je veux remercier de
votre attention
maintenant j'aimerais attirer
l'attention et mais moi j'ai noté vous
vous avez souligné tout à l'heure que
tout un ensemble a été lancé et mis en
place à qui vise à changer notre
conscience des éléments de haut niveau
de leur identité culturelle est et c'est
une stratégie à cette technologique qui
est réalisée aussi par l'intermédiaire
du système de l'éducation
en plus j'ai fait attention au fait que
vous avez dit que très souvent les
actions des élites européennes s'oppose
aux intérêts nationaux et je pense que
vos paroles ne cache pas du tout la
vérité en ce qui concerne le caractère
des guerres contemporaines c'est ce que
nous appelons ici la guerre mentale il
s'agit d'une guerre pour la conscience
pour la vision pour les cerveaux il
s'agit de la guerre qui combine la
correction ciblées de la conscience
aussi bien que de technologies cisco
logique et intellectuelle'
qui vise à changer les moeurs et les
estimations des gens qui vont même pas
comprend comment ils sont manipulés mais
c'est pour ça que je pense que ce sujet
vraiment d'actualité
non seulement pour l'allemagne mais elle
est vraiment vivant pour la russie et
dans le monde entier merci beaucoup pour
votre intervention très brillante et
politique
maintenant je vais présenter l'autre
intervenant suivons avec un très grand
respect je peux vous dire dès le début
parce que le venezuela
c'est vraiment un point douloureux sur
la carte du monde pendant les dernières
décennies
parce que c'est un pays qui subit des
attaques dans tout le domaine des
attaques hybride est elle en parle non
seulement du point de vue théorique
parce que le peuple vénézuélien aussi
bien que leurs et a subi des coûts des
chocs permanent et vous rappeler comment
récemment le venezuela cette
infrastructure a subi une attaque à
cayres et même la source n'était pas
cachée à cause de laquelle l'état s'est
retrouvé dans un chaos vraiment dans le
sens un vrai chaos et ce qui était
vraiment l'objectif de ce qui le faisait
objectifs et cynique
nous savons des tentatives ont eu trait
entreprises pourront faire un coup
d'état
surtout en actualisant des moyens des
procédés de révolution de couleur en
manipulant en déséquilibrant les
situations internes du pays et ennuyant
l'opinion publique a par rapport aux
pays sur l'arène internationale passée
que le rôle de l'armée au venezuela
j'ai déjà dit par le passé parce que
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé du rôle est de
forces armées du pakistan ne peut pas
être surestimée je pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord qu'elle est
extrêmement important d'assurer la
stabilité et surtout pour garantie à
l'existant de ce pays avant de passer la
parole à la john des missions de défense
et moi à mon amiral un beau personnage
j'aimerais transmettre mes salutations
nos salutations
un autre camarade qui est intervenue
lors dans ma section et mes collègues
qui ont suivi et la présentation du
ministre de la défense du venezuela
ici dans cette salle notre grande
camarades notre nom salutations de
camarades
on se rappelle toujours et ensuite
comment vous résistez du patient
héroïque à cette menace hybride qui est
entreprise contre votre pays héroïque
mais dont je passe la parole à monsieur
amiral la bastide as l'adjoint du
ministre de la défense de la république
et bolivarienne du venezuela
merci beaucoup
moyen terme
bonjour chers amis chers camarades
je suis ravi d'être ici
au cours de cette conférence
internationale consacrée à la confier à
la sécurité j'aimerais remercier
monsieur vladimir poutine le président
de la fédération de russie
notre ami vladimir poutine
notre ami cher ami messieurs le général
sergueï choïgou le ministre de la
défense de la fédération de russie et
j'aimerais présenter des excuses au nom
d'autres commandants en chef
messieurs patrie nos lopez qui devrait
rester en même temps aux pays passés que
de nom nous allons célébrer le 200e
anniversaire de la lutte qui achevait à
la lutte pour l'indépendance du pays
institut avec les années passées jusqu'à
présent notre pays continue la lutte
pour son indépendance et la souveraineté
[Musique]
j'ai ramené aussi des citations en ondes
entre commandant en chef
messieurs nicolás mme
ma d'euros le président constitutionnel
de la république bolivarienne du
venezuela qui gère la lutte de défendre
notre pays pour son indépendance et à
l'intégrité du territoire du pays
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi un sujet
particulier dont j'aimerais faire part
avec vous que nous avons appelée et
cyberespace comme champ de bataille et
nos intervenants précédents surtout ceux
qui ont pris la parole le matin elles
jouent déjà fait part de leur
préoccupation concernant cette lutte
cette guerre et l'utilisation du cyber
espace aux intérêts personnels
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les états unis il réalise et
entreprennent des cyberattaques pour
menacer notre pays afin de garantir le
trafic de drogue et leur
commercialisation
vous connaissez tous que le réseau
électrique et du réseau à des points
vulnérables par rapport à ce type
d'attaqué et il y a plusieurs années ils
ont entrepris ce type d'attaqué
malgré le fait qu'il ne pensions pas que
ceci était possible
et en plus nous voyons que des
philosophes partagent leurs estimations
qui aide notre cher ami le président
poutine que les technologies de mines
actuellement aussi bien que
l'intelligence artificielle et domine et
probablement c'est eux qui ont dominé
dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui nous voyons la course au
niveau mondial pour la victoire dans les
résolutions de problèmes technologiques
et de notre côté nous drion on prend nos
connaissances de près des sujets comme
pitching un réservoir cyberattaques y
est crypto devises et toute importance
sur toute autre nation qui est à une
propagation universel montre comment le
monde se développe nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de tendre et là dessus nous
devons toucher plusieurs questions pour
faire part de notre point de vue compte
tenu du niveau des participants à cette
conférence
je veux pas être théorique qu'il vaut
mieux rester praticiens pour mieux
aborder ces sujets non drilles ont
commencé
par une idée très simple deux général
britannique quitter à l'époque la chef
d'etat-major général de la grande
bretagne de 2010 2014 qui a dit que la
guerre fait les armes et réagir et
réagir de façon différente parce que je
parle des paroles du général pig toile
ont surtout je vois que la structure du
cyberespace qu'il a une couche logique
artificielle aussi bien aux couches
cognitive et elle le fait que la couche
cognitives et c'est ici que se trouve le
facteur humain c'est le facteur humain
qui dépend des êtres humains qui peut
être uni vis bleuies là dessus nous
avons plusieurs quartiers de cet espace
parmi lesquels nous pouvons faire la
distinction de plusieurs que le seul
environnement où n'importe qui n'importe
qui peut attaquer c'est la première
caractéristique sans parler des autres
qui existent et qui peuvent être aussi
mentionné en plus ne pouvons voir
quelles sont les menaces est là dessus
parce que ces attaques visent les
réseaux d'état comme lé monde défense et
la vulnérabilité de base de données se
démontre se manifeste surtout pendant ce
type d' attaque il a cette note devions
systémique qui ça devient le sort de
désinformation et 1 parlant de
l'intelligence artificielle ne pouvons
dire
que c'est lié en fait avec des réseaux
est ce qu'on appelle le slicing et ce
type d' attaque qui peut être réalisé
entreprises contre différents types de
services parce que ici à notre menace
comme traite ni d'orgue
parce que dans cet espace si un autre
mine à ce qu'elle nous distinguons ce
sont les suivantes
c'est une collaboration avec des états
dans le domaine de sécurité et de
défense
ces différentes organisations
criminelles qui organisent le trafic de
drogue
nous devons intensifier les mécanismes
d'échangé d'informations entre et parmi
différents aux états afin afin de
réduire les conséquences négatives de
ces attaques et de les simplifier ou
d'alléger dans quelque sens nous devons
sacrifier le mot pour créer des
stratégies de défense dans quelque sorte
et nous devons ça pose et du poisson
très intense afin de détecter et
d'entreprendre des actions de prévention
pourrait réaliser une riposte pour
neutraliser ce type d'attaqués ces
menaces celle là le ce problème et sans
racines lors des forums de ce type là
nous devons discuter surtout dans le
cadre mais au sens de leur mission des
nations unies
comment nous pourrions réaliser un cadre
juridique pour se poser à ce type de
criminels à ce type de pirates
nous sommes dans un tel que son sens
conclusion que nous avons tirée avait
près notre analyse dont la première la
première chose à comprendre ces
dévastations aux gens portés par des
cyberattaques surtout à la population
d'un ampli ainsi que nous avons déjà
entendu parler de du travail de même des
villes qu'ils aient travaillé pour
alizée c'est ce type d'attaqué sur tout
même les réseaux bancaires étaient
paralysés et on en parle aussi d'une
attaque de masse contre le réseau
d'alimentation intrigue notre pays que
nous pourrions citer en exemple illustre
de ce qui s'est passé sur ce plan nous
voudrions trouver des moyens de contrôle
de ce type de système afin de bloquer la
police d'utiliser machine donne
l'intelligence artificielle est pas lié
à ce type de menace
afin de perfectionner les outils des
protections contre cible de menaces et
je dois rajouter comme freineur hoffmann
à dire les doctrines conventionnelle du
xxème siècle vise contre les états l
écran armées de l'époque industrielle
sont de fait morte merci beaucoup de
votre attention
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
allocution illustre merci pour nous
avoir rappelé que nous avons beaucoup
d'intervenants ap des temps alors je
vais pas biaiser de votre attention et
j'ai passé le micro à notre grand ami
représentants de la slovaquie le pays
qui est traditionnellement amicales
avait réussi moi même j'ai visité la
slovaquie en 2010 et j'étais vraiment
touché par le fait que dans les endroits
les plus éloignés lé lequel étaient les
plus petites on trouve des monument aux
soldats russes et soviétiques et ses
monuments sont toujours entretenir en
superbe état et je passe à la parole a
pour président de l'association de
l'amitié russo slovaque jan carnogursky
monsieur le président je vais remercier
de votre invitation pour cette
opportunité après la fin de la guerre
froide
une seule alternative pour la slovaquie
s'était de s'associer à l'union
européenne actuelle les forces externes
et internes appel aux états unis l'étape
de profondeur a commencé deux associés à
la participation à l'union européenne
avec la participation a le temps
nonobstant de notre adhésion au le temps
les liant d'amitié avec les russes y ont
persisté à annuler mans les séries
américaines de sondages publics et
réalisent leurs études dans différents
pays de l'union européenne aux deux le
temps la question de quel état vous
attendez de l'aide en cas de crise
internationale en slovaquie c'est
toujours la russie qui prend la première
place
d'après les sondages de livres et gorée
mais c'est chic aux faits yann barthès
qui joue la roulette russe en slovaquie
c'est le livre qui va apparaître cette
année je donne deux résultats de
sondages sociologique et 41% des
personnes interrogées en slovaquie en
on répond ont répondu affirmativement à
la question sur le soutien de la
politique animé par ouali maire de
routine
c'était le taux le plus important a
parmi les pays voisins et non pour la
question de quel côté serrez-vous en cas
de conflit entre les etats-unis et la
russie vont % des interrogés ont répondu
qu'ils prendront le cas la partie russe
et 6% seulement à abords du rond à la
partie américaine
parmi les 14 pays européennes à oran où
le sondage a été réalisé ce c'est ce
sont les taux les plus importants le
soutien de la russie la pologne et les
pays baltes ne sont pas liés avec les le
sud de la roumanie et la bulgarie à
partir de 2016 jusqu'au début de la
pandémie plusieurs fois par année
en pratique cela et d'autres villes
slovaques
on a vu on a vu des manifestations
publiques de la population contre
l'installation des bases et militaires
de l'otan pour le moment sur le
territoire national nous n'avons que
quatre soldats américains
les médias les plus importants sont au
prix quasiment en totalité à propriété
des agents externes les élites et
politiques slovaques devons respecter
les intérêts nationaux uniquement pour
des cas ponctuels
par exemple le gouvernement précédent
irma de vie a su faire arrivèrent à
fournir la jouissance pique nique paix
en slovaquie au mois de mars de l'année
passée mais n'a pas su l'utiliser d'une
façon correcte à dans le pays et le
gouvernement a été déchue
le nouveau gouvernement s'est porté pour
la privation du droit de vito pour les
questions d'hier et politique externe
on ne pourront pas résister à la
tendance globaliste le président donald
trump
connu le succès dans sa cause en créant
une nouvelle politique et nous avons vu
quelles turbulences été générés par son
souci qu'il a fait chasser de la maison
blanche
une seule exception peut-être générés
par la victoire de marine le pen aux
présidentielles françaises de l'année
suivante c'est uniquement ceux à qui
pourrait revenir à les tendances
globales east and north of dans mon
point de vue c'était état de l'élite
politique européenne peut être décrite
sa part à la théorie américaine de deep
state de l'état de profondeur les forces
armées et notamment leur armée de la
fédération de russie
reste une dernière et ultime a garanti
que ces types state que ne contrôlera
pas le monde entier et que la culture et
les l'indépendance de pays persisteront
la société l'association de l'amitié rue
slovaque a des filiales dans plusieurs
villes à partir de 2006 sans aucun aide
de la part de l'état nous organisons des
groupes qui protège les tombes des
soldats soviétiques
nous avons à notre union en slovaquie
des des loups de nuit sont ces en
groupement des motards
si on a des membres de l'association
internationale des amis de la crimée on
voit l'occident la propagande anti russe
s'est renforcé en même temps la russie
devient l'appui le plus fiable pour le
droit international
à l'international la russie doit savoir
qu'elle a des amis en dehors de ses
frontières je vous remercie de votre
attention au 1er octobre
je tiens à vous rappeler à ceux qui ne
le connaissent pas plus tôt vous dire si
vous ne connaissez pas y entrer en
bourse qui était en décidant assez
connus en tchécoslovaquie
il a même été emprisonné poursuivi et
c'est dom après tout c'est tout remonte
dans de nouveaux contextes de l'europe y
est unifiante il a abordé la position
active de l'amitié rue slovaque et ça
nous fait honneur de voir des amis comme
vous je veux remercier de votre
intervention ayant je veux remercier
encore une fois pour le russe paie 2
la limite des temps j'ai vais faire une
petite modification de nos horaires
aperçu qu thomas greminger vian de
devenir notre salle c'est un politicien
reconnu le chef de centre à de sécurité
dégénère
il n'y a pas longtemps elle a présidé à
l'eau et c'est eux et je veux rappeler
ce que monsieur g une guerre a dit il ya
trois ans durant son interview à aura
des médias russes nous sommes en une
situation tendue et ça c'est pas de
s'aggraver
surtout en ce qui concerne la rhétorique
agressive
malheureusement trois ans après la
tension s'est aggravée jusqu'à devenir
une escale à sion et c'est avec un grand
plaisir et avec beaucoup de respect que
je passe le micro à thomas greminger
vous avez cinq minutes de thomas s'il
vous plaît
je vous remercie monsieur le président
je remercie pour vos propos qui m'ont
fait vraiment chaud au coeur mesdames et
messieurs vos excellences chers amis
avant tout je tiens à remercier les
ministères de la défense de la
fédération de russie pour cette
invitation qu'anticipait la 9e à la
conférence de moscou sur la sécurité
internationale c'est ma quatrième
participation à cette conférence et
j'apprécie vraiment l'opportunité de
discuter des questions d'opportunité a
parmi lesquels je trouve là la sécurité
informatique
je tiens à dire que nous avons
évidemment des solutions que nous
pouvons opposés à des défis alors
qu'elles ne sont confrontés mais quelles
sont ces défis avant tout il s'agit des
défis qui ne date pas d'hier
des informations la manipulation la
propagande de toutes sortes
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau ça
existait depuis longtemps et on a pris
ce qui a changé c'est la vitesse c'est
les thèses de propagation de
l'information au niveau national même à
internationales et régionales et
internationales
c'est le deuxième option qui doit être
prise en considération ce qui me fait
arriver au troisième point ce que
l'accès est disponible pour tout le
monde avait utile et propagation
d'informations massive comme linkedin
facebook ou twitter cet été de manière à
donner la tribune h à caen alors les
gens ont eu cette opportunité de
communiquer librement et facilement ce
qui a contribué à la prospérité du
business mais ces créneaux ces liens ont
apporté une
beaucoup de bénéfices en grand profit
mais les conséquences n'ont pas été
prévus dans les années 60-70 de l'année
du siècle passé
on n'a pas pu imaginer le volume
d'information qui sera disponible pour h
à caen par tous ceux qui ont conçu les
prévenir n'ont pas été nombreux ce qui
me fait arriver à mon quatrième est
quatrième derrière question à quoi elle
qui ne pourront avoir confiance
la confiance aujourd'hui et c'est plutôt
privilège une confiance pour le système
anna ordina tic ou notre confiance à la
précision et à l'accès titude de
l'information que notre vol internet en
prenant en compte chacun de ces éléments
et les problèmes à qui surgissent j'ai
cité parmi les solutions assurer la
sécurité informatique comme le
renforcement de la confiance entre les
parties
comment peut-on accéder à la confiance
dans le contexte du climat politisé et d
un crime en cyber espace de plus en plus
nombreuses
il est important de comprendre que cette
confiance doit être atteint que par le
biais de dialogue et de coopération
je pense qu'il faut que nous comprenions
que la sécurité cybernétique c'est un
problème pour nous tous et qui dépasse
les frontières qui dépasse ses divisions
entre l'est et l'ouest l'occident et de
rien ce problème adore être revu
lui parler mourir de la diplomatie
multidimensionnelle qui permettra de
renforcer l'accord la confiance et
augmenter la transparence ou réduire les
risques lorsqu'il s'agit de dialogue
multipolaire c'est ce dialogue qui doit
jouer son rôle a assuré à la stabilité
dans l'espace cybernétique au niveau
international
quant au niveau régional à
l'organisation de coopération de
sécurité en europe a estimé est en train
de résoudre les problèmes cybernétique
en profitant des mesures visant à
renforcer la coopération dans ce domaine
ce qui est adoptée par les états membres
de se il est à noter que les 57
participants membres de l'essai ont
abordé cette approche commune qui
servait puis liés à la diplomatie
cybernétique internationale et surtout
qui lorsqu'elle est considérée comme une
diplomatie préventive ses engagements
politiques et vise à renforcer la
confiance entre les états rend à
augmentant la transparence entre les
états en réduisant les risques et des
malentendus liés avec l'usld les
alésages des technologies de
communication et d'information c'est
comme ça que ces mesures peuvent
prévenir des conflits en ralentissant
des tendances et de comportements
aggravant enfin il est à noter qu'il ait
jamais suffisant d'opter en lui de
rédiger un document ou d'adopter une
approche tout ce que le reste est de
faire c'est de profiter de sept tirs
pour l'amp les montées en pratique
ça reste est nécessaire pour que les
mesures soient efficaces lorsqu'il
s'agit du niveau bilatéral le sommet
récent russie russie etats-unis qui a
lieu à genève la semaine passée nous a
fait preuve de l'importance de dialoguer
pour surmonter des différents comme
monsieur poutine a déclaré aujourd'hui
lors de son allocution d'ouverture
bien que les deux pays ont une grande
expérience à part et les menaces
cybernétiques la dépistage des sources
de ces menaces et l'examen des points
sensibles de la forte culture reste des
kills des problèmes très importants et
le dialogue reste en outil primordial
pour prévenir aller sur les retombées
des attaques ces derniers tickets afin
de restaurer la confiance entre les deux
pays
je pense qu'on a rien de pire que
l'image est négative
créé pour l'un ou l'autre pays
c'est toujours fort dommage lorsque les
pays est miné la confiance mutuelle en
profitant de cette menace cybernétique
pour conclure je tiens on dire que mon
centre jeunes et vient de politiques de
sécurité que je préside un présente en
cat forme neutre pour un dialogue
inclusif a pour discuter des questions
sécuritaires
nous sommes au centre de fab
international genève nos experts sont
sans parti pris son fusil vais en
dépendant avec notre expérience avec
notre réseau global
ça permettrait à de présenter une
plateforme efficace et peureux dialogue
et la coopération c'est ça ce qui ne
manque parfois dans le monde actuel
et nos sens que s'ils occupent dans le
domaine de la sécurité cybernétique je
vous remercie de votre attention
nous avons encore plusieurs
en terminant je passerai la parole à
tout le monde à nous allons dépasser
notre agenda pour une comptine dix
minutes
j'espère que vous n'allez pas l'envié
d'un ce retard à mésanger pas cela
peyrolais représentant d'un pays qui est
vraiment à aimer d'entre eux pays après
le temps de pire le grand jeu passait
par leurs représentants des pays bas au
pays que vous avez vous avez cinq
minutes
je veux où je veux remercier largement
pour votre intervention est pour se
rappelle de l'époque de pierre le grand
je commencerais par remercier le
ministère de la défense de la fédération
a mais aussi pour cette invitation de
participer à la conférence d'aujourd'hui
qui ne servira de plateforme pour
l'échangé des expériences à vos débuts
des années catherine 80 du siècle passé
dé santé des milliers des européens ont
descendus dans les rues pour protester
contre le déploiement d un missile
balistique et pershing hall 2a en guise
de réponse le déploiement des missiles
russes s ses 16 ans ces missiles sont
maintenant exposés au musée de
l'aviation et à washington pour ne
rappeler qu'en 1987 le président reagan
et le sécateur général gorbatchev ont
signé un accord d'interdiction des
missiles nucléaires et conventionnelles
avec la portée de 500 jusqu'à 5500 km en
4 e vente et 11 l'union soviétique et
les états unis ont fait détruire
quelques 2500 missiles
c'est en traité qui a fait l'europe plus
sécurisé peut-être mais c'est la fin de
la guerre froide qui a rendu l'europe a
plus sécurisé malheureusement maintenant
c'est plus le cas on parfois on parle
dans une nouvelle guerre froide si nous
n'allons rien faire c'est la nouvelle
guerre froide que nous allons témoigner
mais
ça sera une nouvelle guerre froide
il faut restaurer la sécurité et et
lancer de nouvelles mesures comme on
peut le faire je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec les intervenants
précédents la confiance la confiance qui
est servira à prévenir les essais
étaient militaires à limiter les
activités d'exercice mais les terres en
assurant des inspections sur l'ailier
ces mesures doit être restaurée
différents traités au plus entre assurer
la sécurité ne sont plus respectées au
sont annulés même l'administration
américaine a quitté d'elle-même à le
traiter le ciel ouvert le monde est en
changement irrésistible sécu non on
forcera à changer nos approches dans le
domaine du contrôle désarmément le
contrôle global désarmement c'est une
mission très c'est très importante
on a beaucoup d'acteurs trop doctes
acteurs dans ce domaine
lorsque nous avons trois quatre cinq
participants de convives me retraités
c'est toujours très compliqué de trouver
en point comment alors se rend à obliger
de prendre des décisions au niveau
régional les japonais sont actives dans
ce domaine y compris un pouvoir
stabiliser les sistema d'armements
conventionnels à a limité les armes
conventionnelles à discuter les
doctrines des militaires pour assurer la
sécurité dans l'est dans le domaine
cybernétique et dans l'espace
peut-être un jour ce deviendra possible
de discuter les répartitions d'esquerdes
influence mais là nous avons une
complicité majeure comment est-ce qu'on
peut les tracés saison en plus ans c'est
quasi impossible
je peux vous jurer que la majorité deux
majeurs politiciens à l'occident sont
opposés à toute sorte de convention qui
prévoit la participation d'autres
acteurs avec leur propre opinion
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit des
représentants des pays qu'ils n'aiment
pas ils me je pense qu'il est primordial
d'écouter et d'entendre les positions de
nos partenaires nous les européens
nous n'allons pas nous devons pas
sacrifier notre seule unité dans le
domaine de cycle de la sécurité de la
défense
ça reste à gré gouvernements nationaux
évidemment en participant dans des
alliances et des unions nous sacrifions
le volet économique de notre activité
parfois mais la défense et la sécurité
c'est trop on pousse pas le bouchon
aussi loin que ça nous allons au
promouvoir au développement des traités
maison la sécurité commune en europe
l'essentiel c'est vous de voir ce
changement de paradigme
alors ce qu'on commence à réduire le
niveau des discussions sans l'usc pleut
à l'union européenne ont le discute au
niveau régional
en fait on le joie dans les relations
entre les états unis et l'asie d'asie
maintenance c'est le centre des intérêts
américains et qui me fait discuter les
autonomies européenne du façon
stratégique et ce qui est tout à fait
différent au contexte que nous avons
témoigné et les plaisirs année
évidemment valorisation des nations
unies doit à faciliter ce dialogue est
rompu en disant à une certaine autonomie
indépendance et simultanément
lorsqu'on assiste à cet esprit de
compétition qui vient d'être mentionné
qu de nombreux pays ont des programmes
de dissuasion nucléaire alors les
opérations les campagnes cybernétique et
peuvent devenir des outils pour la lutte
pour le pouvoir
il est important de sens de se rendre
compte de leur influence sur des
questions économiques
pour conclure je veux dire que la sortie
des traités que je viens de mentionner a
rendu l'europe - sécurisé il faut
écouter
il faut que nos écoutions il faut que
nous nous entendions il faut que nous
comprenions les malheurs des ans des
autres pour éviter des malentendus et
des erreurs des mauvaises calcul ce qui
ne fera générés ont une approche tout à
fait nouvelle aux questions sécuritaires
olives à l'échelle européenne
attention sur ce que y en est ruty par
des experts mais les terres de l'europe
a pas ce que je suis allé annoncer et
surtout l'allocution de monsieur le mans
thermique devant les téléspectateurs
repères
ce qui le fait le brussels donner un
héritier c'est surtout je pense que
c'est loin d'être la vérité on va fixer
ce point
chers collègues il ya 22 ans messieurs
de véhic a parlé de l'automne il ya 22
ans nous avons vu l'agression sans
précédent de l'automne contre un pays
formidable de communes yougoslavie qui a
été fait ce bond suivant le schéma
hybrides ou d'abord la tacc informatique
a été lancée pour diviser la population
interne
ils ont lancé les mécanismes de
révolution de couleur avec un colleur de
confession et en résultats avec de
nombreuses victimes la formidable le
pays a disparu et jusqu'à présent pour
nous les russes
cette leçon extrêmement importante
sérieuse
nous n'oublions jamais surtout quand
nous entendons les promesses orales
avant de passer la parole au président
de l'union des anciens combattants de la
serbie participante en bière et un
militaire général majeur commandant y
avait cela kovalchuk j'aimerais tiers
votre tension parce que je viens
d'apprendre par hasard je parle de
colonel les autres dany mon colonel
le vélo s'il vous plaît parce que c'est
vraiment il ne
jaune une vraie légende de la
yougoslavie c'est le commandant de
l'unité de combat de l'armée de
yougoslavie à l'époque qui le 27 mars
1949 a abattu l'avion invisible le blake
hockey est fait 117 ha en utilisant un
système soviétique entier rien they
125ème c'est vraiment un très grand
honneur de vous voir parmi les
participants mon général
kovacevic imitons je vous rappelle quand
même et cinq minutes à respecter
mesdames et messieurs pour moi c'est un
grand honneur de participer ici à cette
conférence et ça fait le 20ème
anniversaire ou l'allemagne attaque
80e anniversaire ou l'allemagne attaque
et l'union soviétique où l'armée rouge a
remporté la victoire non seulement mais
aussi la libérer toute l'europe
quand je me pose la question pourquoi
l'europe ne célèbre pas le 9 mai en tant
que jour de la victoire
j'aimerais remercier les ministères de
la défense de la fédération de russie de
m'avoir invité on peut représenter les
anciens combattants de la serbie au
cours de cette grande conférence et nous
avons dit que nous n'avons pas nous
adhérer à l'automne et quand même
j'aimerais remercier le président gucci
tch les 19 pays du monde compte et hakim
pettitte et services sans avoir
l'autorisation et la sanction de l'onu
quand ils ont été lésés les avions
invisible que nous avons un boîtier
surtout les bombes intelligentes avec d
une orange enrichit la serbie est un des
pays les plus puissants dans cette
région surtout sur le plan politique et
social
nous produisons notre propre vaccin
grâce à la russie sur toi son président
monsieur vladimir poutine et nous avons
de bonnes relations avec la russie aussi
bien qu'avec la chine comme avec
d'autres pays et du monde
merci beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup de votre intervention
surtout pour le fait que vous avez
respecté cinq minutes de votre
intervention
j'espère que cette compréhension sera
toujours respecté à part un expert
italien mais jamais mais gégé
j'ai du mal à me poser la question parce
que vous êtes expert italien qui gère
une succursale une antenne à paris qui
se spécialise dans les sondages et sur
les questions de défense et la mise en
place de structures de défense est
conseillé de structures de l'otan à
bruxelles
alessandra nazis
cinq minutes depuis votre place merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
vous avez tout à fait raison je suis
italien ma société c'est une société
italienne
nous avons une antenne à paris mais très
souvent je travaille à bruxelles avec
une commission européenne c'est pour ça
que parfois j'ai du mal à m'identifier
d'eau julien quand ce qui est surtout et
j'ai du mal aimante a titillé ma
citoyenneté c'est ce qui est vraiment
extrêmement important pour les
cyberattaques au pour compenser ou sas a
commencé une cyberattaque bonjour
mesdames et messieurs
tout d'abord j'aimerais remercier les
organisateurs de la 9e conférence de
moscou sur la sécurité internationale
surtout le ministre de la défense de la
fédération de russie
merci beaucoup pour m'avoir invité
intervenir lors de cette conférence
[Musique]
j'aurais du mal à respecter cinq minutes
est vraiment c'est pour ça que je vais
au m quelques planches et je vais les
sauter pour faire l'économie du temps
ceux qui veulent avoir la présentation
complète veuillez laisser vos cartes
d'affaires je vais envoyer ma
présentation complète merci beaucoup
ma présentation est consacrée aux
différents problèmes et vladimir poutine
a donné un interview
médias allemands il n'ya pas longtemps
et là-dessus j'aimerais me rappelait les
paroles de charles de gaulle tient porté
beaucoup d'attention à la sécurité
et en plus d'avoir présentation
j'aimerais couvrir les questions
concernant l'intelligence artificielle
voilà ce sont les heures sup est tout à
fait différent que j'aimerais combiné
dans notre présentation ici dans ma
poche ici voyez un exemple de la
technologie parce que ce petit outil
mais permet de switcher et de chercheur
et de changer le diapo et je vais parler
de la sécurité de technologie et du
financement de ces recherches
j'aimerais dire à cette phase en russe
le fantôme se baladent en europa et
quand même ce serait plus simple de
parler anglais
un fantôme se baladait travers l'europe
de quelle forme s'agit-il c'est un
fantôme de la peur de notre propre
sécurité
parce qu'à l'époque faisait des années
1930 40 c'était et peur face au nazisme
et aux approches nazis mais probablement
au futur nous allons nous inquiéter à
propos des changements climatiques parce
que nous comprenons que des problèmes
liés avec l'écologie augmenté aussi la
pénurie des ressources naturelles comme
l'eau seront en croissance parce que par
le passé et à présent la seule
possibilité est le seul chemin possible
pour réagir et faire face à tous ces
menaces et une coopération surtout en ce
qui concerne coopération scientifique et
dans le domaine de technologies
je parte d'amour d'une coopération
internationale parce que c'est une chose
et notions extrêmement importantes et si
nous parlons des garanties de la paix en
europe c'est extrêmement nécessaire et
en plus haut sur le plan européen
on aurait pu atteindre tous ces
objectifs grâce au travail de deux comme
été il ya 15 ans ou 50 spécialistes ont
essayé de définir quels seront les
menaces au futur et qui sont le
résolution parce que les comités on
fonctionnait depuis 2005 jusqu'à 2010
ils ont été essayées de prévoir les
menaces et du futur
jusqu'à présent nous essayons de trouver
ces solutions
nous essayons d'utiliser les mécanismes
de financement des recherches de ce type
parce que ça fait partie de programme
horizon 2020 fpc et d'autre
je vais citer quelques exemples pour
mieux démontrer et détaillée de ce que
je parle
il ya un aspect important le fait que le
financement en question dont je parle
il est d'ici non seulement au pays de
leur opinion ici au pays qui se trouve
en dehors de l'union européenne de quoi
je parle quand j'en parle
il s'agirait des pays sur l'autre partie
de l'océan atlantique
parce que à son époque charles de gaulle
a déjà cité entre autres l épi de
l'amérique latine comme par exemple le
brésil avec lequel ne confierons pas ce
que d'un projet qui vise à protéger les
forêts en plus le travail ont aussi dans
les régions d'oural on ne travaillons
dans le domaine de la lutte contre le
commerce est des valeurs de culture et
l'ermitage a été invité à joindre ce
projet nous devons être prêts pour faire
face aux défis de demain
nous devons atteindre une autonomie
stratégique et dans ce but il faut
développer les technologies et clé aussi
bien que le potentiel stratégique afin
d'assurer notre disponibilité et dans ce
but
actuellement l'europe commence à
financer son programme de défense
mais pour le réaliser il faut préparer
ce qu'on appelle une fenêtre
scientifique
il faut réaliser des recherches là
dessus je peux citer trois projets mais
je pas détaillé comme j'ai déjà dit
parce que sinon le président va couper
mon micro
maintenant je vais passer à la partie
numéro 3 imaginez vous en train de
réaliser des recherches mais quand même
de l'autre côté la cyberdéfense et les
problèmes de l'intelligence artificielle
ici j'aimerais citer le premier exemple
naturnes où je suis le coordinateur
scientifique dans lequel ce projet
parce qu'ici nous essayons d'utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
domaine de la reconnaissance pour
protéger nos citoyens contre la menace
continue du terrorisme et c'est un très
bon exemple de coopération en europe
mais non seulement en europe mais aussi
en dehors de ces limites et de ses
frontières
parce que en complément au pays alors
permis à des pays comme la jordanie le
cren de la grande bretagne la macédoine
la bosnie herzégovine
tous ces pays participent à tous ces
projets notre projet et qui concerne la
cyberdéfense la cible sécurité d'une
part et la défense et la protection de
l'autre côté ce qui est vraiment
d'importance
une autre projet qui a paru en 2020 qui
s'appelle échos sorte de squelette
pour le nouveau centre de compétences
dans le domaine de la cyber défense qui
sera placé à bucarest
merci beaucoup monsieur le président de
la session merci beaucoup cher
participants de vos trois attention je
sais que j'ai essayé de respecter est
cinq minutes italienne avec
l'alourdissement français mais chez nous
au sein du ministère de la défense ne
coupons pas les micron parce que nous
ouvrons la possible des haches
comment est maintenant je vais passer la
parole parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
entendu une allocution très brillant
très sévère du ministre de la défense de
biélorussie parce que ces derniers six
mois 12 mois
ce pays subit une pression deux formats
hybrides
sur tout l'éventail des menaces
possibles étant j'aimerais passer la
parole à un sergei makarov qu'il est
l'auteur du concept et ou au sein du
ministère de la défense et aussi de
conseiller de la sécurité artificielle
et servier vous avez cinq minutes russe
maintenant je jeff cher participants
s'il vous plaît ne l'affiché pas ma
présentation j'ai essayé de me limiter à
cinq minutes on a utilisé les thèses et
les sujets suivants parce que les
paroles de vesely parce qu'actuellement
sur le champ et dans le cadre de cette
session mais non nous sommes en train de
voir pour la première fois un consensus
très fragile du fait que les piles veut
se mettre d'accord sur la sécurité
informatique parce que ça me donne une
sorte d'espoir que les propositions de
la république de biélorussie sur toutes
les plateformes porteils concerne les
propositions suivantes vienne année nous
avons subi une influence impact
informatique as importante mais notre
position n'a pas changé depuis
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce matin le
ministre de la défense de la république
de biélorussie et déjà dit on nous
essaie de penser que le scénario
militaire est inhabitable mais quand
même
la chose la plus évidente il faut passer
une sorte de phase chaude
une fois qu'une quelques incident
informatique ait lieu ou une quelconque
événement informatique cervin ou de
cette façon comment nous pourrions
réaliser sort de riposter nous opposer
quelle est la recette de la république
de biélorussie que nous avons déjà
utilisé dans le cadre du concept que
nous avions adopté il ya deux ans où
nous avons une position qui s'appelle la
neutralité informatique ou nous agissons
pour démilitariser
le sujet de la sécurité informatique
parce que c'est une sorte de leurre et
déjà plusieurs spéculent qui ont déjà
dit qu'il n'y a pas de mécanisme de
bonne conduite informatiques dans le
domaine informatique et cela veut dire
que à travers cette fenêtre on va passer
dans une quelques phases chaude c'est la
première chose deuxième chose nous
appelons à utiliser ce type de mécanique
comme sauveur nt une informatique et
nous essayons d'utiliser cette approche
dans notre pays pourra garantir la
suprématie la primauté du droit
sur le plan informatique quand les états
puissent être été le segment national de
l'espace informatique une autre position
que nous respectons et que nous
favorisons c'est la politique de la
sécurité régionale au sein de la
sécurité du deux organisations sur le
traité de la sécurité régionale et dans
le cadre de notre 'new état unifié et le
concept de la stratégie informatique qui
n'existe pas parce que nous agissons
pour na prochain ensemble pour assurer
la sécurité de le plein informatique et
je propose de regarder cela sur le plan
des pays des lacets hui à cette question
est réalisé à travers les statuts
concrètes pour la réaction aux menaces
concrètes et
juste quelques propos au sujet de cette
commémoration des quatre vingts ans a
depuis le début de la grande guerre
patriotique et pour nous les biélorusses
c'est la date très importante en
commençant par les sauces par le 75e
anniversaire de du début de la guerre
nous assistons à des tendances qui
visent à miner cette mémoire à faire
oublier à la victoire à faire des petits
misé réfectoire il faut du respect pour
cette pour pour cette guerre qui a servi
à au peuple de trouver de la force et de
la fierté nationale
je vous remercie pour conclure je
passerai le micro à un pays qui en force
sans son influence mondiale je passe la
parole à un politologue kerim casse qui
présente à la turquie c'est son opinion
publique
je tiens de souligner je vous remercie
chers collègues je tiens à vous
présenter juste en deux mots les
derniers outils utilisés par la turquie
dans le domaine de la politique
extérieure
la turquie reste parmi les pays ayant
rédigé les documents concrètes pour
assurer la sécurité informatique les
attaques et cybernétique et contre notre
pipeline à au passé nous ont fait tirer
de leçons c'est attaquer et leurs
conséquences ont été assez désastreuse
kinki ce qui nous a prouvé le lien avec
les problèmes et régine ans et la
confrontation militaire dans la région
ces attaques et nous ont aussi a ouvert
les yeux sur l'importance des
infrastructures sensibles
alors maintenant nous avons toute une
structure avec 13000 experts officiers
de sécurité qui forment d'antropov
cybernétique
je dirais sont angie des deux ministères
des transports et des infrastructures
haut dans l'administration de
l'industrie de défense est bien sûr au
sens des deux forces armées
à part les orients étatiques les
sociétés privées sont nombreux le vrai
dans le domaine de la sécurité en plus
de 5,80 société assure la sécurité
informatique à cybernétique pour leurs
clients
désinformation et la propagande et et
sûr utilisé par nos adversaires
politiques
sous la direction du président nous
animons les discussions au sujet des
questions sont opportunes de la
politique intérieure et extérieure prix
accrue
de la participation turque dans la
guerre de syrie a fait augmenter notre
activité nous avons utilisé les drones
en libye en syrie en haut karabakh
nous avons posé les fournitures de ces
drones à de nombreuses autres pays alors
l'élargissement de l'otan à l'est est de
mon point de vue c'est d'un air j'espère
me reid qui correspond à l'expansion
turc à la surface cosmétiques
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils nous avons une
coopération accrue dans ces régions en
coopérant avec tous ces pays besoin
cumulant l'expérience des guerres
hybride au caucase à nuque renner notre
pays
ankara et moscou route ou pour gérer les
risques vis de ces menaces hybride c'est
bien hybride fait ça c'est un fait
nouveau dans la politique extérieure
turque qui sert à à énimie et la
diversité du régime bergen a en tant que
le deuil national en renforçant son
influence personnelle et créant le vide
de ce qui se vit de sécurité rend en
turquie et dans les régions complet 1
entière étant donné que tout ce qui
concerne la sécurité et accès à une
seule personnalité
le gouvernement turc effet diversifier
les outils des guerres vide à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
à part les forces de sécurité et des
forces armées en trouve des structures
en forme elle
des tendances politiques et au sommet
politique et qui sont sans sont pas
parus en turquie et est content ce que
nous voyons se renforcer il s'agit des
sociétés militaires privées comme java
des hostilités l'été des proxys combats
en syrie et d'autres pays
toutes sortes d'associations hausse
paramilitaire comme des gardes de nuit
et ancien de suite les toute sorte
d'union islamique turque que certains à
un bassin de turquie qui sont utilisés à
des pans de la lutte et brident mais
n'est pas la turquie allait à
l'extérieur à toutes sortes d société de
consultation et de formation sont aussi
impliqués à ses activités
l'une des sociétés est présidé par l'ex
général de brigade qui a gardé ses liens
avec le service de sécurité et des
forces armées
l'activité de ces sociétés en syrie et
en libye dans d'autres pays
célian direct et en ville avec les
groupes peuvent radicaliser s'en font
souvent couler de l'encré des médias
turcs eux ils ont participé à una à
tentative dans coup d'état en tirent qui
en 2016
bon soit disant coup d'état pour en
conclure je dois dire que en ce qui
concerne les acteurs d c'est l'été et
bride
on trouve parmi eux de troupes pas
régulier
et des sociétés militaires privées des
organismes non gouvernementaux
je crois que les acteurs étatiques et
privées jouent sur ce champ de bataille
le rôle simultanément participants à
cette guerre hybride pour assurer la
sécurité globale en 2021 il faut
comprendre les règles des guerres
hybrideurs lorsqu'il est quelqu'un qui
ont fait appel
personne n'est sécurisé il faut trieront
dialogue 2.0 pour que le majeur acteurs
sous l'égide de l'organisation des
nations unies puis secret rédigé en une
nouvelle stratégie visant à assurer la
sécurité à l'échelle mondiale à ce
travail à être encouragé même en ces
principes doivent être mises à jour avec
le respect des intérêts de tous les
participants en soulignant l'importance
de monde de la paix dans le monde entier
dans le vent tignes circulaire le
comportement des grandes puissances et
plus ou moins prédictible le si nous
voulons avoir bloc à sécurité il faut se
faire orienter assez assez ses confrères
primant le comportement mais parfois de
parfois il faut prendre en compte et en
considération le contexte plus large
je veux remercier de votre attention
chers collègues et malheureusement je
n'étais pas présente et le micro tous
les cas ce que ceux qui veulent
intervenir mais j'espère que notre
discussion a été animée mais en charge
et
je remercie de la part du ministère de
la défense farouche participation
pourrait présenter revend sion bien en
charge et s'en sert croyez moi tout ce
qui a été omis durant vos interventions
vu le manque de temps qui sera publié et
pour conclure je dois dire bon on m'a
dit que nous avons vu peu de temps c'est
vrai mais je sache je me suis rappelé du
sage et un élève le demandeur sur m
alors m et selon temps d'attendre à la
cause les re création si on s'attend
s'est longtemps notre objectif d'assurer
à la confiance mutuelle nous n'avons pas
à attendre
il faut travailler une fois est vrai
sinon le monde sera géré par la peur
dont vient de parler notre caméra de
fonctionner a missionné benza
représentant permanent de la russie
auprès de l'onu
je vous remercie chers collègues pour
votre travail je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée et une bonne journée de travail
de demain